[Music]
radiate boundless love towards the
entire world
a disciplined mind brings happiness
give even if you have only a little
[Music]
love
conquer Badness with goodness conquer
meanness with generosity
conquer dishonesty with truth
drop by drop the water pot is filled
likewise the wise man Gathering little
by little fills himself with good
I will not look on another's Bowl intent
of finding fault
a training to be observed
Delight in heedfulness guard will your
thoughts
should you find a wise critic to point
out your faults follow him as you would
a guide to hidden treasure
should a Seeker not find a companion who
is better or equal let him resolutely
pursue a solitary course
in whom there is no sympathy for living
beings know him as an outcast
tread is Never appeased by hatred in
this world
by non-hatred alone is hatred appeased
this is a law eternal
live with no sense of mind not forming
attachment to experiences
all conditioned things are impermanent
when one sees this with wisdom One turns
away from suffering
ardently due today what must be done who
knows tomorrow death May Come
to support mother and father to cherish
wife and children and to be engaged in
peaceful occupation this is the greatest
blessing
all tremble at violence all fear death
putting oneself in the place of another
one should not kill or cause another to
kill
they blame those who remain silent they
blame those who speak much they blame
those who speak in moderation there is
none in this world who is not blamed
just as the great ocean has one taste
the taste of salt so also this teaching
and discipline has one taste the taste
of liberation
if with a pure mind a person speaks or
acts happiness follows them like a never
departing shadow
as an elephant in the battlefield
withstands arrows shot from bows all
around even so shall I Endure abuse
the root of suffering is attachment
whatever precious Jewel there is in the
Heavenly worlds there is nothing
comparable to one who is awakened
it is in the nature of things that Joy
arises in a person free from remorse
Purity and impurity depend on oneself no
one can purify another
[Music]
ceasing to do evil cultivating the good
purifying the heart this is the teaching
of the Buddhas
understanding is the hardwood of
well-spoken words
[Music]
just as a solid rock is not shaken by
the storm even so the wise are not
affected by Praise or blame
[Music]
we will develop love we will practice it
we will make it both a way and a basis
there is no fear for one whose mind is
not filled with desire
[Music]
whatever is not yours let go of it
you're letting go of it will be for your
long-term happiness and benefit
[Music]
meditate do not delay lest you later
regret it
[Music]
whatever can arise can cease
[Music]